Danneel immoral combat don't you I love
I love an X amount of time so yeah we
just checked our world combat X today
not 10 no no it is kind of combat no
it's more like about 28 at this yes so
they kind of announced this back at e3
starting to see more of it now they
announced some new characters why don't
you let me know how you feel about it
cuz you got more hands-on time with like
I did I got to play it they showed us a
little demo which showed off I guess
some of the new mechanic II stuff where
there's variations on combat so now
before you go in you can basically
choose from three different variations
the base moves are there for your
character but you are basically focusing
so you're talking about on like a per
character basis yeah so recording can
either be fire scorpion or teleport a
scorpion or like a voodoo scorpion right
where you could like summon that demon
yeah there's none where we just use
knives and stuff yeah so you know adds a
little bit of variation I guess there
yeah but yeah when I was playing as you
were saying it looked smoother
definitely felt smoother and all the
combat as opposed to Street Fighter has
always felt very much like I don't know
start stop or yes my staccato that kind
of yeah exactly that is the move where
is this a bit more flow to it and the
you know in saying that Scorpion and
sub-zero felt like Scorpion and sub-zero
and but I really enjoyed it like I don't
know what it is very more combat where
whenever they make a new one for some
reason I don't think it's same II tried
nonsense but I actually yeah I was into
business talking about flow they also
added a lot of things I mean they had
kind of had this end injustice as well
where you can interact with your
environment but rather than just sort of
throw the enemy into something or throw
the environment at them you can now sort
of use things to say jump over the head
of someone you have to get behind them
like I think we saw Sub Zero like
swinging on a tree branch and get behind
him but uh well I know one thing about
subs here that you really loved
can throw your ice could throw your eyes
closed ice cone pick up your ice clone
throw your eyes to cook just which is
just a really rare in a better way of
just doing the ice thing yeah that's
like yeah but it had some more character
I think yeah what I liked the better as
well it there seemed to be much more of
a degree of like hey
singing involved in your attacks so like
with the ice cone it's like you do the
ice cone but maybe he's gonna throw it
on me when I was playing some of the
larger characters in it
they're like standard mortal kombat doc
and triangle uppercuts you were like
easily 50% longer so the the movement of
the characters as well is different
based on their size and scale and I
found out really entertaining because
for instance one of the things where
more combat is the mini you know
somebody's jumping you're ducking and
doing that in the figure - or is in this
one you could kind of like do people in
detect you couldn't do it yeah and then
load it up and anything they see I'm a
street fighter guy play Mortal Kombat a
lot when I was a kid but I sort of like
Street Fighter for me has evolved quite
a lot this is the first time where I
feel like I'm actually interested in
moral combat as a fighting game versus
just sort of you know the mortal combat
experience of this dark world with these
characters that do horrible things to
one another and speaking of that though
some of the fatalities we saw were their
price of new characters so new
fatalities totally as well the some lady
was made of like some sort of bees or
something there's this big overtime
that's going in the Edit there's this
big hulking dude who's got this kind of
little girl on his back and he basically
like held on to for Johnny Cage and I'm
what's-her-face suet sue what's her name
Johnny Cage is Sony blades daughter it
was Cassie blade Cassie Cassie blade
Cassie cage has a cage she basically
looks like ya know that it's got yeah he
held onto her and then the little one
like stuck her knives in it and I jumped
over head I'm bisected or I haven't told
her of PARs disgusting I don't want to
say that's Mortal Kombat in a nutshell
that's more of a comment in this Mortal
Kombat a nutshell I like this but it
looks more fun than ever at least for me
someone who doesn't usually play well
combat all right thanks Danny no problem
yeah for continuing coverage of Mortal
Kombat X and Gamescom 2010
for continuing coverage of more common X
and cubes Con 2015 our continuing
coverage of Mortal Kombat X and Gamescom
2014 Fiat iTunes to games.com